whoa
oh no so somebody gonna hold the
conductor
damn that gets more intense every time i
swear
off the freaking rails we're back
you know what it is we were never gone
today's episode is sponsored by credit
karma curology mint mobile and upstart
we love you
[Music]
a lot of people now let me explain
something for some people okay
um while elo was gone she came back on
tuesday we were having fun and
experimenting
with different formats our original plan
was to kind of take the day the weeks
off to
take a break but i was um
lonely and sad and thought it would be
better to work
and what we did is we were experimenting
on twitch
twitch tv we were doing live streams
there
and it was fun you know we had a good
time with it some people here were
they were upset i guess that we were
posting content on twitch
and not on youtube but for us it was
just we took that time to experiment
with a new format
but you know i understand we are not
going anywhere we are youtube forever
we are we live for our members i would
lay down my life for any one of you guys
i like that in a heartbeat
if you need a long can i have survived
without a lung
that would be no half a lung i don't
believe so
well corp suspect can wow that's quick
that was pretty good that was pretty
amazing i have to say
but um i would donate half of my long to
you and take my chance
any one of these members so i just wanna
anyway we prepared a little bit of a
sketch for you guys well not a sketch
it's really just a video of our meeting
we had because twitch was such a hit
i thought well let's diversify and put
content on even more platforms to
confuse you guys
even more so with that being said here's
our pitch to you guys for more content
guys i bring you here today because
i am wanting to branch out our content
more
i know we're on twitch and i'm thinking
like
the more platforms the better
you know a lot of people were really
upset that we've been streaming on
twitch right are you
aware of that um
well well maybe it's just they don't
like twitch maybe they prefer to watch
it on like a platform that they're
they use for example i've been thinking
of doing like a facebook
live show facebook live but that way
in that way if they don't like on twitch
they can watch it on facebook live it's
a whole new
show by the way facebook live on
snapchat we could do a show
uh connect with our younger fans
no no no no no take some dms dm us
that's awful let's avoid the snapchat
yeah trailer
is obviously something we've been
talking about i know that like
it's been getting a lot of one-star
reviews but it is a platform
not a good one but a platform i mean
it's flipped
it is flipped so that would be an issue
right okay
dyspo hmm dyspo's dead
oh megel so omega is interesting you
just have to it's like luck of the draw
we do a whole show
for one person to luckily connect to us
on omegle
only it's gonna be a lot of dicks it's
gonna be a lot of dicks
just dick snake content too all dicks a
lot of
really zach you're gonna do that you're
that wasn't necessary but okay
e-bombs world e-bombs world i mean
there's still people there
what is something what is that e-bombs
oh you're making me feel right 1990
1980 okay so this one's interesting you
know when you get into a taxi cab
and then on the back of the head rest
there's a screen that they run like
commercials on
so i'm thinking we could do a show
specifically for the back of taxi cab
head breasts
i hate those things everybody hates
those yeah but then you put good content
on it and what's good about that is that
they can't
turn it off right so they can't they
have to watch it so that's what i like
about it it's like
here it is you can't enjoy it i see your
vision
yeah who even takes taxis anymore it's
all uber
okay stop looks genius stop you go to
new york you wanna
yeah you better be in new york come on
we got it come on now
you get him okay this one is kind of
like the taxicab one
pop-up ads you're on your favorite
website pops up behind
boom h3 podcast the show the pop-up
experience
it's there you hear it it's there it
just pops up
pass i i blocked that suggestion you
would block that
yeah that's a good point a lot of people
use block uh unskippable youtube ads
unskipable unskippable youtube ads so
like a tai lopez style thing
lopez and sometimes you get youtube ads
where they run for like an hour
can't skip them that's what i'm
interested in so like somebody's like oh
i don't watch pewdiepie i don't watch
dream nope you're watching h3 podcast
for an hour unskippable
got him new fan immediately yeah i don't
know if they're going to be happy about
it
we need growth we need to grow the
channel so
clearly people don't want to watch the
show so we need to force them
to watch the show and that's why i'm
saying billboards digital billboards
just project the show live onto a
billboard
obviously you can't get you need someone
with like a speaker so zach i was
thinking you
could just stand below this the
billboard with a big audio absolutely
i think that's a great idea i don't i
don't agree to do that
why it's good exposure it's a building
yeah
people drive by you pull over hd podcast
you don't have anything to do in roblox
um
insider roblox the video game atrium
podcast and roblox experience
like a little nos x style yes
roblox mcdonald's drive-thru menu
i'm sorry the mcdonald you know how
mcdonald's has digital menus so it's
kind of like
well obviously dan you're gonna have to
contact mcdonald's to seal that deal
but i think they would be happy just to
lend out their digital menu
for our show for people doing a
drive-through so dan i'm gonna need you
to get on that and talk to mcdonald's
okay
and then finally you know there's pub
which is good
people are watching what's better what
you've had what's better than going from
being you're
watching some guys uh schtick that's
what twitch is for
yeah i thought that's what twitch was
should we just stay on twitch
tv boba boomba that's what like amaranth
is
and booba yeah what the [ __ ] is bubba is
that
all right well let's just stay on twitch
then cause these these ideas don't seem
very good how about
here's a revolutionary idea yeah a3
podcast
record it post it to youtube
our youtube channel oh we have a youtube
channel called the history podcast right
right genius let's do that
we're back funnily enough um we are so
here's the deal here's what's actually
going to happen
h3tv forever if you go to
uh h here it is i found it h oh no this
is someone else's channel excuse me h3tv
i'm going to need you to beat the fo
well i only have one video on but anyway
i made a channel called h3tv
and here's the new thing our schedule is
going to stay
the same here it is [ __ ] yeah
h3tv schedule's going to stay the same
but instead now we're going to be doing
h3 tv on monday and thursday
for just like a couple hours and because
like we like to play video games and
we're planning on playing minecraft and
just reacting to a bunch of stuff on
stream on twitch
we're going to put we started a new
channel for h3tv
here if you want to subscribe um
i don't know how you find it just type
h3tv i'll put we'll put the link in the
description
hell yeah oh my god dream's excited
about us playing
uh minecraft let's go
so this is gonna be fun and it's not
gonna take away anything
from this channel here nothing changes
this is just a fun little
a passion project it better not it's
going to be it's not dan you know that
or not
you know it's not people were big mad
it's just they were big men
i know i was taking the week off and i
decided to do
footage but i understand they said we
didn't communicate enough so
okay here i am i'm communicating exactly
what we're doing it's just a chance to
diversify as you said
diversify you said diversify believe no
i did not you may have
i did not say diversify get your word
straight jack
[ __ ] um
yeah it's just it's you know what it is
it's the crew dynamic we're all gonna
friction around
mess around have some fun very loose
goosey
stuff that people on the podcast channel
don't necessarily want to watch okay let
the conversation so if you want to let
the conversation begin
head on over to h3 tv a link in the
description
thank you thank you thank you thank you
peace and love peace and love
also teddy fresh collection comes out on
thursday just to plug either real fast
because she's back and she deserves
all the [ __ ] this is a new shirt by
the way
that's coming out on thursday 10 a.m
it's really nice it's an embroidered
flowers come on
i mean how else do i describe it anyway
get over teddy fresh on
instagram for updates but here's a
little preview
of the stuff coming out boom
boom work it work it people
these jeans ela made are amazing it's
got her
it's got all ela's art on it and the
jeans are like fire so come on wow
sister
snap so anyway here's some of the you
know you get the idea
thursday 10 a.m teddy fresh.com give a
shout out to ela because she's now being
sued by ryan cavanaugh
i'm not going to talk about that too
much i'm going to talk about on friday
with her but yes ryan cavanaugh
this guy right here and i'm not gonna
talk too much about him but the guy who
looks like harvey weinstein
whose partner accused him of running
a ponzi scheme um
is suing now ela she's he's suing ela
and teddy fresh you're on the wrong
street cause
exactly so anyway tune in friday for
that whole explanation because that'll
be fun
welcome back eli you're being sued
that's the title of the friday episode
anyway my family's back it's so [ __ ]
nice to have them back oh my god dude
it was so empty the house was so empty
uh
theodore is immediately a menace to
society
he came home sick and jet lagged
obviously
so like last night for example i was
getting ready to go to bed around two or
three o'clock
and um he wakes up
because he's jet lagged and like um
usually when he wakes up at two or three
it's really easy to put him back to bed
but he starts going daddy i'm not tired
he goes daddy not tired
daddy downstairs so daddy didn't sleep
at all where's your daddy
but he's so cute he's so happy he's so
nice he's sick though
it's like his first time being sick so i
feel bad for him he's got this little
cough
like really hacky like anyway we're
going to doctor tomorrow so
take care of the little shrimpy um
anyway it's so fantastic having them
back god i miss them so much
i forgot elis pregnant kind of because
when she came back i was like oh what
the [ __ ] you're pregnant
we're having another kid she kind of
forgot
dan i have something i need to talk to
you about
dude when are you gonna make a move i
literally said dan it's in your corner
people are yelling at me
because this chair nothing's happening
with the chair i put
it on the table if it's all in dan's
corner now dan you could be in this
right now
what excuse do you have well so first of
all i did reach out to this company
and they did not get back to me
apparently they don't want a sixteen
thousand dollar sale
what are they selling to who i don't
know answering uh calls from i reached
out
and they did not get back to me maybe
they get a lot of trolls
okay but like still what are you how
many i don't know but
listen i reached out but i started to
look at
the um this could be i know this could
be me but i'm playing
i started looking wait wait wait i just
noticed something really funny
the tube hits his foot on the wall
spinning oh no
the tube of holding the monitor hits his
foot you're right yeah
move your foot watch your foot buddy
take your foot off
thing looks a little janky to be honest
with you
yeah uh what caused some hesitation on
my part is i looked at the the footprint
for the thing and i
i genuinely don't know how the [ __ ] we
would get it in
the studio like i would like in this
space where
oh yeah no you'll have to be you'll have
to sit somewhere else i know which is
kind of i'm not really i'm not really
vibing with that oh
come on i mean i there's lots of
show things i have to do to like
actually
i know i know and also listen so i found
another one though
it would take you a long time to get out
of this chair like look how slow that is
oh it's
like dan i need help with something and
then you're like hold on
it's obnoxious it's kind of amazing
though
but yeah the uh the base of it would
basically take up
from the wall to past abs desk over here
it would be
oh basically yeah it would take up okay
so what did you find
you found something else you want yeah i
sent it to you right the uh send me the
link so the people can see it
um who what who is this built for like
drone
people killing people with drones in
afghanistan like i just don't get it
this music makes it so much more badass
yeah the music's sick for sure i could
just
i should just download this put it in my
mix
you know my youtube mix uh
uh uh alexa play the soundtrack to
ergonomic desk 10 please
[Applause]
alexa play the zero gravity ergonomic
desk 10 please
hell yes
[Music]
are you sending me the link dan uh i'm
trying to oh i just found it
i found it all right so this is dan's
alternate for to the zero g
and i have pledged sixteen thousand
dollars to your cause i don't remember
we set up some kind of this and this was
if i recall this one was actually
cheaper here which i love by the way
yeah because 16 000 let's let's be
honest that's that's going to hurt i
mean that's a lot of money yeah
so this i feel like it's a worthy
uh successor to now how much is this one
i think it was like eight grand or
something but it's it's a [ __ ] tank
it's got mini guns on the side
it doesn't have live ammunition i
unfortunately i don't think that the
miniguns are functional i think it's
it's purely for show does it move does
do the tracks work i don't think so
either i think it's just it's supposed
to just so it's just a dumb
chair yeah but the the whole top the
roof thing like
raises and lowers like a scorpion it's
so stupid
so it like kind of like drops in in
front of you you know who's buying this
[ __ ]
we are yeah so that's gonna fit in where
you're currently sitting uh
yeah i mean so its footprint is much
longer this way
um but that that's manageable much more
than this way so
is it to be so [ __ ] amazing every
time we cut to dan he's in this scorpion
tank
gatling gun device fully reclined by the
way
yep wait the first one the 16 grand one
it's that big
like it's massive it it yeah it looks
yeah no it's huge it's huge it's like
nine nine or ten feet
across horizontal it would i i measured
it out
it would be it would basically replace
all of this this whole
well yeah i mean look how big it is like
he's sitting almost lengthwise and it
looks like it's wider than his whole
body
worth it oh this is a tim and eric
sketch i mean this is on adult swim at
3am there's
this is it zero g command module
i sent you a video of the other chair oh
yes the police and i just found it
it's six grand six grand ten thousand
dollars cheaper
oh another one i was wrong actually this
one's a little bit different than what i
said this one's all scorpion
so that's actually the same thing and
that's like the normal ver
the normal version of it and then they
have a special edition that's all decked
out like a tank and that's the one i
want oh wait but look at how the
scorpion flexes that's [ __ ]
sick dude what yeah so i believe this is
made by the same company
and um that's crazy yeah but the tank
doesn't have that cool scorpion motion
oh it does that's what i'm trying to say
hmm
but it's so cool with the scorpion um i
think tanks are cooler than that look
it's here
it's for your call it's your personality
this is so insane like who would buy
this that
isn't just goofy yeah i guess that i
guess that isn't the exact same
uh model but i believe it is the same
company that makes that thing i'm
actually really curious if this thing is
comfortable
and actually like functional or if it's
just horrible and you hate it here
the one that you're looking at the
scorpion is 3 500 wow that's pretty good
deal for all that motion
yeah the tank is 3 900.
that's cheap dan for like that much no
the tank
no there's the base model which is
[ __ ] that's thirty nine hundred
wait the base model wait send me the
website i wanna
appear here here here's the link right
here okay so we're not getting the
the base mod we're getting the one that
shoots live ammunition exactly
okay so here's the scorpion so
so this is also called zero gravity
right i think that's a little bit of a
misnomer you're very much
fat ass is sitting on a chair but if you
keep scrolling down
see this is like the standard edition
and then if you keep scrolling you're
going to get to the special edition down
below this
yeah so here's the thing
wow you have to be a real [ __ ] weirdo
it still does the the motion
nice is it is it like mobile does it
roll i don't think so i think it's
purely i think the tracks are purely
yeah it says the gun and the track are
only decorating but
as far as the gun i feel like i love
they need to clarify the gun's only
decoration
i feel like we could get somebody with
some
know-how to mod it and at least turn it
into like a nerf gun shooter or
something so i could just like well why
don't we add some
real tracks to it too and get your ass
down to hollywood boulevard
if you're down to go all out on it then
absolutely well you know we're saving 6
000 on that other one
10 000. i believe the other one was 16
grand
that would have hurt i'll be honest
spending 20 000 on that thing would
would
yeah after shipping taxes and everything
would have been close to 20k so
this is this is a better bang for your
buck it's still amazing
it's maybe cooler i mean it's got a
[ __ ] minigun gonna be [ __ ]
terminator dan up in here
i need a video of this one okay so here
it is in real dude that's your kitchen
bro your whole kitchen is just dedicated
to this dumb thing look
he's like this is my life now like
exactly that's a good question where do
you put this he's like it's in my
kitchen where else am i going to put it
oh and they've got the single ultra wide
monitor that would be cool too
although for a lot of stuff i do i need
multiple monitors i don't know so
they'll install them
i mean that better be a good monitor
they might install a [ __ ] monitor on
there because
like a good monitor is gonna price you
at like one two thousand right off the
gate
yeah i don't think it comes with a
monitor i think it's bring your own
monitor bring your own byom i think so
because it supports up to three monitors
this looks like kind of oh it supports
up to three that's perfect
i use a triple monitor setup for the
show so oh i'm sorry that's the
workstation
ultimate is that the one you're
referring to no no this is the this is
the
i forget what the name of the business
the j20
pro uh i'm not sure about the second
thoughts
it just it doesn't look that cool in the
photo
excuse me what the hell well you're
looking at the wrong one
oh i am oh is this the bad one that's
the that's the female one scroll down
scroll down oh that's fourth time you're
going
yeah you're you're in this is plebeian
where am i
i'm lost i think you might have gone to
a different page or something all right
well
whatever we want the tank make make it
happen make it happen
okay make some calls make it happen or
well if you just
let people know at least it's not my
fault i'm not holding it up
it's true it's not even i blame i i
blame the i gave him a blank check and i
said dan
i think because remember when we
initially found out about it
and a b was calling them and stuff and i
i strongly
with peace and love the foot soldiers
may have gotten carried away
and started calling them and i think
that they started to think that
it wasn't real and so they never got
back to me
shame because they were about to make
their only sale of the decade exactly
no i was shocked i i sent a follow-up
email too i was like hey i'd really like
to purchase this you know what if
anybody listening actually owns one of
these chairs i'd love to talk to you
you know we've been talking about it for
quite a while now and nobody's ever
yeah i mean now that they're like hey i
have one is this yeah i don't know
maybe for christmas i'll buy you guys
all one of those
we can all have them the mini guns oh
sorry look
my dad over here playing why am i doing
this what are you doing i just i don't
know i saw something from ela
and i opened my phone during the show
and it just started playing sound
okay boomer yeah sorry it's because this
show's authentic we're just hanging out
not that authentic there's just the
group of guys being dude
so listen we've got a lot of great stuff
here truly off the rails experience
um you know um
by the way just a side note trailer is
like it just seems like they're getting
a lot of one stars lately
and i don't want to i don't want to dig
too deep but i just will say
something's going on where they're
getting a lot of one stars
and i hope it's not you guys leaving
those reviews because if i find out you
guys are leaving one star reviews
i'm gonna be very unhappy because what i
want
well no if that's your real experience
then that's fine and i endorse
absolutely
yeah if you have a one-star experience
then i encourage you
to go rate it a one star if you had a
negative
review of it but if you had a great
experience then i re encouraged you to
go give it a five star
that's how the rating system works
yeah it's all about opinion and
um an opinion is is not
uh actionable uh it's so awkward
right well that's so noah beck for
example will give it a one star
based on that he might not just because
i think that he's being paid
right right i think but anyway i just i
i don't actually know that i know that
triller and ryan cavanaugh are upset
about the
number of one star reviews now i i don't
think it's coming from you guys because
i encourage you all to be honest
with your review so if you're leaving
one star reviews on
trailer just make sure that's your real
experience because if you do like
trailer
leave more than one star right honestly
so i want you guys
because i'm i'm interested in triller
and it seems like
they really like the interaction they
really
like people coming and leaving ratings
and so i encourage everybody to go leave
a rating
on triller between one star and five
stars based on your experience
but i will tell you they're very upset
about the one star reviews
and so i don't want you guys to just
leave it one star because
of what i said yeah ethan's
opinion is his and his alone now let me
be clear
i left one star but that's based on my
experience with
the app okay so
that's all i want to say about that so
they're getting very upset about the one
star review so i encourage you guys
to keep leaving honest reviews
right all right to five stars up to five
stars which is the max right
so keep it up guys or four or three
two or one stars exactly that's how the
rating system works one
on five i i encourage you to keep up the
honest reviews and honestly
but if i find out you guys are leaving
one stars just because of what i'm
saying
i none of you guys would do that i know
you guys you wouldn't do that and i
would be very upset if you did do that
you guys should have seen him
behind the scenes before the show well
because even
stomping around
you're encouraging people to leave one
star reveals and i was so outraged by
that
i said how dare you accuse me of
telling people to leave a one-star
review
it's in the complaint they filed a new
complaint we're going to go over it on
friday but i said
how dare you accuse me of telling my
fans to leave one star reviews i never
said that it's an outrageous assertion i
said once
or more yeah or five stars or less
that's like it's obvious
self-explanatory
yeah people so people know how the
rating system works exactly i don't need
to explain how the rating system works
anyway that's all i'll say about that
for now okay peace and love thank you
guys
yeah pretty amazing actually
you know what's amazing though i'm going
to say this
just one final thing on this because i'm
fascinated by social media
as a social media star myself
you don't you don't buy the star claim
well when
when we when ryan cavanaugh sued me they
were sitting at a 4.8
and right now they're at a 4.6
that's two tenths of a point down which
is pretty good uh
considering um
they have a lot of ratings so i'm
assuming a lot of you guys are sharing
your experience with the app so
that's good okay
fantastic it's not good that it went
down that's not my point it's good
that you guys are leaving your
experiences which is what how are they
going to improve
if they don't get honest feedback well
some people might be giving it five
stars
right so honest feedback is all i want
you guys to get honestly
you heard it here i want you guys to
give them lots and lots and lots
of honest feedback honestly
all right you guys want to talk about
joe rogan's nipples
finally joe rogan's got some mummies
some mommy milk or nippies
i love these nippy nips
i can milk joe rogan
all right so joe rogan of course is on
that alpha [ __ ]
posted a picture of himself in an ice
bath for
20 minutes i mean that's hard i mean i'm
impressed i guess if
i don't know i guess i'm impressed what
i'm really impressed with
nipples actually like an inch like what
well i was just going to say we propose
that you do the ice bath
as part of this discussion today and and
ethan was just like i i don't think i
can do it
well here's what i why i didn't want to
do it is because this is what would
happen
i would get in and out in one second it
would be for nothing i'm not doing i'm
just telling you i'm not
i can't do it i don't have enough just
not
alpha i don't have enough alpha brain
coursing through my
blood for this apparently joe rogan
drinks like anti-freeze
i think there's anti-freeze in alpha
brain actually that's one of the
ingredients
joke all right i don't know i mean i
don't know what we don't know yeah it
could be
i think they're probably not i think
there's anti-freeze and alpha brain
we've got enough lawsuits on our head
i'm not a doctor i'm a [ __ ] [ __ ]
exactly thank you joe rogan said it
anyway he uploaded himself in an ice
bath of course he did and
and here it is it's generated a lot of
memes
so it's like the whole 20 minute video
he posted
look we all have our interest i was
playing final fantasy 14 all night and
joe rocco was sitting in the ice bath we
all have our interests
[Music]
okay here's where it gets interesting
jesus man you don't have to be in that
water joe
oh so okay so this is just an excerpt
but from it yeah yeah
but the real interest okay so what
really was interesting for
us here in the office um
was his nippies when like when he comes
out of the water
here here's his whole instagram post in
case you guys are curious
um 21 minutes
oh hello friends just got done working
out i'm going to try the
let's see if we can spot see what his
nips look like pre workout
comparison again and hopefully i can get
more time this time uh i figured the
best way to do that is to hold myself
accountable and film it so here we go
oh let's just take a look at his nipples
here
as he gets in
[Music]
okay oh boy okay nips look
they're a little big they're actually a
little they're already a little pokey
yeah they're
they're quite pokey already actually got
some ice picks man
diamond cutters eh oh yeah
man you could like you could like uh you
know his nips are kind of big to start
to be honest uh you guys go to 20
minutes and 40 seconds okay so 20
minutes 40 seconds baby has timed it out
perfectly
he's memorized yeah you beat off to this
be honest no
i mean whenever we first saw this video
that was my whole theory like when he
got out
wow look at those [ __ ] milkers bro
that looks like a cat like a mommy cat
that just had kittens
and she's right getting ready to milk
and i'm not i'm not to body shame joe
because he's obviously very fit and
healthy
he's great i mean he looks great better
than me but he's just got
it's just funny to come out of a bad ice
bath with big ass [ __ ]
pokies
man
[Music]
you could candy those man put him in oh
my god wait that's even crazier
i could chisel a rock with those you
think he's packing two percent
two percent milk probably more five
percent eats a lot of fat
oh my god you guys it's five percent
milk it just still
you could climb at mount everest with
those things
i'm sorry joe but this is awesome
yeah you could you could drill to the
center of the earth with those things
so anyway that was that and we had some
fun with it obviously so
so we've prepared an album of joe rogan
nipple themed
uh memes for you guys pleasure
okay the polar express two
off the rails
what's the joke here exactly oh i see
his nips are on the
rails okay i didn't see the nips oh my
goodness
gracious the nips are the spikes
yeah and it's polar express like the
movie right right now
i was just looking for his layered it's
layered no i was just like where are the
nips
this looks like ace family
he's getting out of the ice he's trying
it's cold they don't eat that huh
apparently not it's cold water in the
ace family i guess they are being
like sued and foreclosed on so they
probably can't afford heating yeah
that's what that means expensive
oh no oh no joe rogan's nipples for eyes
that's some toe broken [ __ ] right there
that's nightmare fuel
that is definitely
sleep paralysis demon oh this is kanye
has joe rogan's nipple on his head he
did have that flesh
oh and then this was our thumb our
thumbnail for the vr playthrough for
half-life
well we thought well what if what if
instead of an alien it's joe rogan's
nipples are strangling
that looks straight out of the game not
gonna lie looks like a creature it's
honestly more
than anything in the game yeah
so there you have it uh joe rogan's
nipples ladies and gentlemen
[Applause]
do we have jill calling in uh
i think we might be able to get him on
the line but we first need to go to
break okay so when we come back
it's not gonna be it's just joe was mad
that like oh
oh ela's here too okay we're actually
doing a
so papa john's been i'm gonna go to
break when we come back papa papa john
popeyes pop eyes
has been saying that they have new
chicken nuggets that is going to
revolutionize the chicken nugget game
they've been saying that
and did we order them or something yes
we did of course we did
okay is that news to you no i knew that
you ordered popeyes i had no idea it was
for the show
yeah it was for the popeyes okay got it
it's hard to tell sometimes
baby [ __ ] fried chicken i'm gonna be
i don't think how do you make chicken
nuggets that revolutionize the game i
don't know
i doubt it so we're gonna find out after
the break stay tuned that and so much
more
off the rails time to take a short break
[Music]
who doesn't want instant gratification
if you're looking for satisfication
there's no need to wait
with a credit karma money you could win
cash reimbursements
for debit purchases what
here it is credit karma money is a brand
new checking account where you can win
cash reimbursement for making your
purchases when you use your credit karma
money debit card
you can win daily instant karma purchase
reimbursements on items
up to five thousand dollars just pay
with your debit card
and if you win you'll be notified on the
spot and your instant karma
cash will be added right back to your
spend account the one thing i like to
say about this is that debit cards
usually don't have
cash rewards that's what i find so
interesting compelling about this
so if you don't have a credit card you
don't want a credit card you can't get a
credit card
this is a great incentive so that you
can kind of get rewards for using your
card at the same time
uh credit karma money has already given
away over three million dollars in
instant karma to over 50 000 credit card
members and counting so open your fdic
insured
spend account for free there's no
minimum balance requirements
no overdraft fees free withdrawals from
a network of over 50
000 atms credit karma money progress
starts here
and right now visit creditkarma.com win
money
to open your free account and start
winning instant karma
go to creditkarma.com one money to sign
up for free and start winning that
instant karma that's credit card.com
when money instant karma is sponsored by
credit karma no purchase necessary
exclusions and terms apply c rules
banking services protofi mvp banking
incorporated members fdic maximum
balance of transfer the mid supply
i used to think that my greasy face
could never attain the skin goals that i
wanted
and i have to give a shout out to cure
ology because even though i've only been
using it for a short time
i actually really feel the difference
you know it's so hard to find good
beauty products that actually
are tailor made to you and that's the
beauty of curology
these are real licensed dermatologists
so you send them you tell them about
your skin you send them pictures of your
face
and what they do is they formulate a
perfect cream
with the just the right ingredients to
treat your face so what they do is they
send you
a cleanser your custom formula
to treat whatever's going on in your
skin and then special moisturizer
i mean it's so cool it's taking care of
the skin is like such a mystery i feel
like and that's why i love this service
you're trying to take control of acne or
if you know acne is not even a top
concern if you've got fine lines dark
spots occasional breakouts or clogged
pores curology custom makes a
prescription formula
with three active ingredients picked for
you to tackle your
skin care needs to get your treatment
plan start by answering questions online
about your skin and sending in a couple
of selfies
next curology matches you with the
licensed dermatology provider
gets to know your skin and if it's a
good fit you'll get the customized
prescription cream right to your address
and we're going to treat that skin of
yours baby um
like i said it's just it's one two three
it's so nice you don't have to think
about you don't even think about it dude
then curology sets you up with a
personalized treatment plan
and ships your custom formula right to
your door um
listen i already love it
and dermatologists are annoying it's
like
just another crap you have to do don't
skip all that
take control of acne dark spots
breakouts or whatever your unique
concerns are maybe with the powerful
skin
care treatment made just for you today
go to curology.com
h3 for a free 30-day trial just pay for
shipping and handling that's
c-u-r-o-l-o-g-y
dot com h3 to unlock your free
30-day trial see curology.com for all
the details
[Music]
after years of fine print contracts and
getting ripped off by big wireless
providers
if we learned anything is that there's
always a catch and when i first heard
about mint mobile
and the premium wireless services that
they offer for just 15 bucks a month
i thought what's the catch but after
speaking with them
and dan has been using their service for
quite a while now it all makes sense
there is not a catch mint mobile secret
sauce is that the first company to sell
wireless services online only
and by cutting out retail stores there's
no crazy overhead costs to get passed
down to you
in the form of mysterious fees instead
mint just passes on the sweet savings
directly to you
it can offer the same quality of service
at a much lower price
dan be straight with me how is your mint
mobile service
it's great i had uh one of the big
carriers
i won't say which one for years and uh
so and i was fairly happy with the
coverage that i got so i was a little
skeptical
but they just sent you a little envelope
with the sim card i already had an
unlocked phone
pop that thing in bob's your uncle
honestly
it's as good as any other wireless
service that you could get
and what's crazy is like how much you
paid like what's the cost it was like a
hundred
hundred plus versus 15. yeah i was it
was my
cell phone but was literally a hundred
dollars a month and it went down to 15.
so
i mean hard to argue with that it's hard
to argue with that for people looking
for extra savings mint mobile offers
premium wireless for just 15
a month all plants come with unlimited
talk text and hide speed data
delivered on the nation's largest 5g
network use your own phone with any mint
mobile plan and keep your same number
along with all your existing contacts
and if you're not 100 satisfied mint
mobile has you covered
with their 7-day money-back guarantee
switch to mint mobile
and get premium wireless service
starting at just fifteen dollars a month
so to get your new wireless plan for
just fifteen dollars a month and
get the plant shipped to your door for
free go to mintmobile.com
h3 that's mint dot com
slash h3 cut your wireless bill to 15
bucks a month at mintmobile.com
h3 so many americans have experienced
financial hardship in the year
upstart can help you regain your footing
and get things back
on track that's because upsar is a fast
and easy way to pay off your debt with a
personal loan
all online whether it's paying off
credit cards consolidating high interest
debt
or funding personal expenses over half a
million people have used upstart to get
one
fixed monthly payment upstart knows that
you're more than just your credit score
and expanding
access and is expanding access to
affordable credit
unlike other lenders upstart considers
your income and current employment
to find a smarter rate for your loan so
find out how upstart can
lower your monthly payments today by
going to upstart.com
h3 that's upstart.com h3
don't forget to use our url so they know
who sent them
thank you loan amounts will be
determined based on your credit
income and certain other information
provided in your loan application
remember guys upstart.com h3
milady welcome back everybody from the
break
um listen i don't i know you guys don't
like this i don't want to do it
joe rogan is blowing up our phone once
again yeah i've gotta bring him on
let's just get this over with okay joe
cut the [ __ ]
you really have to do this every time
okay joe what do you want to say about
your hard nipples
what's going on man good to see you whoa
wait show me that that is an image of
joe rogan's name
written out with his nipples in the tone
of his foot that's amazing joe did you
write those with your nipples
like what do you think about it listen i
think everybody's beautiful in their own
way and
i think you have big beautiful nipples
there's nothing to be ashamed about
if you lost 200 pounds you would feel
wonderful
that would be healthier like if you
smoke every day and you're like look no
cancer
smoking's healthy no no you're just
you're just your body
is dealing with it your body's
processing it
it won't be able to forever that is
exactly what's going on if you're
morbidly obese and for you to pretend
any differently
and to just go on about this fat
acceptance
show movement come on man you know the
big beautiful
this and that and that's no you're obese
you've eaten too much food
if you see a fat guy how come he doesn't
have the same
treat
no one's saying he's beautiful because
he's disgusting
and he's fat and he's lazy and he's he's
all right
because we're talking about his big
luscious nips he can come on he said if
i lose 200 pounds i mean
if i lost 200 pounds i'd weigh 20 pounds
joe i don't know how feasible that is
but i deserve that so i don't
you're you know you're being humble
right now but
nobody deserves that that that was
really rude that was really
fine i mean i i made fun of his nippies
he can
he can make fun of my fatness
zach is very tickled by that yeah if
someone made this sound
board it's [ __ ] amazing it has
everything
h3soundbytes.glitch.me what the [ __ ]
that glitch
listen to this [ __ ] uh it's got
everything
keemstar shut up shut up [ __ ] it's a
beautiful [ __ ] thing
i need that clout it's got everything
look at this this is
thick like up there carlos bassman
so if you scroll to the very side very
bottom of it if you go all the way down
yeah there's a lot holy [ __ ] there by uh
some paradise if you if you click on
that got them
fried chicken wednesday who deserves
fried chicken me oh the windy wheelies
you know in a way it's a beautiful thing
it's like a culmination of work and you
know looking through
does this make you feel good seeing this
it really does yeah we hate keemstar
like it's an honor like it's the
dedication to your craft
yeah some parents are freedom for the
world and you can click on any one of
these and it's like [ __ ] nice
it brings back so much memories like let
me just scroll at random here
what am i gonna do every single one of
these is iconic watch i'll
just stop here what are we gonna do it's
all iconic
let's go over here ian please stand up
they're all good
s-i-m-p blew my tits right off my fat
body
i've never played that one yeah that one
i was just gonna say that that's kind of
a fresh one
oh no i mean yeah you can just scroll
and scroll
frustrating i'm not a cat
you know joe biden wake up
this is a this is this is just love you
ugly
and how he cuts out all the faces it's
pretty it's just really amazing i mean
no eating fatty
round of applause for um the person that
made this
some paradise if you go go down to the
bottom you should stop if you think she
should suffer
click click on the name down there yeah
some paradise like that this is really
[ __ ] cool
so who's the i can't tell who's the i
think it's the girl
oh oh well shout out damn you gotta roll
some paradise
you real girl get after it
what the [ __ ] it's so amazing so i'm
throwing up
me daddy i'm telling you you could click
on any one of these the mark with that
one
this [ __ ] picture she picked it's all
good
i'm gonna come extra large and extra
hard
yeah so shout out and most importantly
keemstar shut up shut up that one's new
yeah within the last week or so it's new
but it's good you're keeping it up to
date
it's new but it's good yeah so shout out
i'm impressed
all right we've got these um okay
popeyes is out here making some really
insane claims and you know the last
off the rails before you look comes back
on friday i thought let's eat some
[ __ ] food
fried food here's what popeye's out
there claiming some insane [ __ ] so i'm
going to be
brutally honest with you guys
they should be paying me to watch this
[ __ ] man hello how you doing today
oh i just wanted some nuggets can i get
some nuggets
what a whole bag that'd be great you
guys are so great we're here to share
the love
what is this commercial av thank you so
much people are going to be
i don't know i'm sorry there's like a
whole story first it was a war
there's two videos that i sent the first
one was the one the chicken
okay so they're saying the war is over
these are the best nuggets ever made
here's these
nuggets are gonna heal the world okay
is that zach can i be honest zach did me
dirty
zach yeah zach anyway here's this
chicken sandwich
[Music]
these are like we made billions off this
war we need to keep it going man yeah
well i'm here i'm not gonna pull any
punches on your chicken popeyes
zach we order these nuggies for the
express purpose
of eating them on the show and i'm going
does everyone have nuggies and zach's
like i already had one
i'm like what why did you you ate one
already we're not
we're we're doing this for the show well
i have to be fair everyone else was
having some
so who ate nuggies of you guys back
there before the show
be honest with me
i don't think anyone ate nuggets zack i
had one [ __ ] nugget
but that's the whole point is that our
reactions are supposed to be on the show
be fair to zach you didn't really make
it clear that we were yeah oh
come on i thought you were just getting
popeyes to have food yeah somebody
backed me up here you spontaneously will
order things like we got nuggies for the
show
okay well i'm backing up ethan thank you
a.b no problem
[ __ ] sake of course he does yeah also
to back up ethan a little bit
and we know ian doesn't like to back me
up go ahead ian when they brought the
nuggets over for us to get ready for
this segment zach's like oh don't know
i said i'd have one on the air i said
i'd have one what happened
i had one before and i'm gonna have one
on the air why one before
i wanted to try it did you try i don't
know i've been
so good on my diet this [ __ ] [ __ ] is
calling and haunting me why do you need
two
just have one on the air i i [ __ ] up
i'm sorry thank you
that's all i wanted i gotta say to zach
i don't want to dog pile on you but i
was giving you this whole speech about
how a man who has discipline
everyone else and you're like thank you
a lot and you're gonna tell me you
[ __ ]
[ __ ] sandwiches and fries and [ __ ] i
didn't have any of that i had one
[ __ ] nugget
it doesn't matter the quantity of the
nugget it matters the context of the
nugget
the context of the nugget was in was was
not appropriate context for a nugget
eating so you could have had 10 nuggets
do you want my review they would all
have been
let's well we all got to catch up now
but here's the thing i will also say
zach is on the weight loss journey and
he's been
such a good boy he's been through he's
been um resisting temptation so thank
you thank you
for that but shame on you for the nugget
making fun of my big salad bowls who's
the one eating healthy here
it's not about okay here i asked for
lots of sauce you guys
here's my first review of popeyes can
you see the desk
no but it just yeah if you just do that
yeah
yeah yeah they delivered chicken
they delivered on the promise of sauce
can i just make a quick point real quick
it is fried chicken wednesday
oh fried chicken oh fried chicken baby
great point i just start fried chickens
[ __ ] wicked i do deserve fried
chicken yeah chicken wings do you guys
want any of these sauces you guys want
to come
so here's what the nuggies look like
they're just i mean they're super fried
they're just like super fried so here we
go
you guys cheers some stuff
i already stole one am i am i allowed to
eat this now or should i wait
zach you can eat it now obviously we're
doing this segment
i'm gonna take a dip i mean it's a it's
a very crispy nug
is this ending the war
is this ending the war
they're saying you've never had a nugget
like this i've had nuggets like this
everywhere in the world i have a
question
go ahead what's the difference between a
nugget
and a tender mmm interesting point
i think a tender is like one piece of
chicken where the nuggies
chunks of meat okay
i don't want to call anyone out but
someone in the office was hyping this up
a lot and even after she tried it
said uh you mean the one female cast
member the one female
said i it was amazing well sam why don't
you come here
if you don't mind because you are like
the ch the chick-fil-a
connoisseur the fried chicken
connoisseur
so why don't you tell me what's so
special about these nuggies
i loved them i thought they were awesome
but i mean
it is kind of like just their regular
chicken
breasts like on a sandwich just like cut
up is what it tastes like like there's
no
there's nothing different really i see
and the difference between a nugget
and a tinder is it's a chicken
tenderloin versus
like pieces of breast cut up i think
there you go ian you just got dunked on
by your own girlfriend
so now the uh the blackened ranch is my
favorite sauce
blackened ranch blackened what the [ __ ]
is that what does that mean
yeah there's blackened ranch yes it has
like blackened seasoning in it
i have a piece here that looks like a
tender
is this a tender or a nugget let me
inspect that's not
i think that's just like a super deep
fried nub this is this is
i'd call this a small tender no
that's not a small panda it there's a
very specific definition i've
i've looked it up and um as you alluded
to the tender is a from a single cut
of chicken whereas the nugget is an
amalgamation
yeah no you were right credits credit to
you
well done i don't like the blackened one
who deserves fried chicken
meat okay is it good is it a good nugget
yeah it's pretty it's good
is it changing the game no so
here's the question who's got the better
nugget then i don't know i'm not really
a nugget guy
is it better than a tr than a a mcnugget
yeah it's better
nuggets is like mcnuggets you're gonna
piss
careful look
mcnuggets are good i like them you have
already been canceled by the k-pop
community once
ethan oh they're they're like
they're like dedicated to the nugget now
that's in the pizza bts's favorite food
look i like chicken nuggets but what you
get from popeyes
is real chicken what you get from
mcdonald's is like chicken paste
that's been like cooked into the shape
of a nugget
to be honest you're not wrong let me ask
you have you ever had tyson chicken
nuggets
tyson yeah it's kind of like this though
tyson chicken nuggets
are personally they're my favorite and i
think they are the best
um what you all think of dino nuggets
dino i [ __ ] with dino nuggies
[ __ ] with the dino nuggies dino nuggies
is like there's there's two type of
nuggies in the world there's the paste
nuggies
and there's the real nuggies dino
nuggies is a paste snuggie
and some people like to pay snuggie
people say oh it's gross it has bone and
cartilage and eyeballs and
[ __ ] net i say i don't give a [ __ ]
what's in it
you're using all the chicken i think
that's great what am you're just
supposed to throw it out when you can
make a nuggy out of it
what the [ __ ] do i care if it's got
ground up chicken penis in it i don't
give a [ __ ]
right it tastes good right you got you
guys [ __ ] with those el salva halal
nuggets
the [ __ ] you say el salva hello nuggets
like halal nuggies they're like yeah you
could buy it in the store like
in my hometown they're not that good
[Music]
that's really inappropriate zach how
[ __ ] dare you
why because he said hello zach can you
play the wally sound
zachary what are you trying to say zach
nothing
i got nuggy dust these are probably the
best
fast food nuggies i guess well that's
what we're rating it against right
yeah i mean that sounds well they say
it's like an endorsement
i'll say that i will say that oh i'll
say that these are the best fast food
nuggies well you were down i mean you
were downplaying it
no that's i think that's all they're
claiming
that's all popeyes is claiming i think
that they're the best they think i got a
hit on chick-fil-a i'm with i'm with
mcdonald's
you like the mcdonald's one yeah i think
we're saying that this is better because
we don't have it as
often but long term what could you eat
i'm gonna disagree with you i i get the
mcnugget
i think it's a i think it's a preference
thing um
you know you prefer chicken goo squirted
in your mouth that's like pretending to
be
they call it um what do they call it uh
separated
partially separated mechanically
separated chicken parts
you know the chicken nuggets just a it's
a sauce vehicle
first and foremost right
right so what sauce are you using with
it i'm not using any sauce on these and
they're still pretty good
that's true that's true oh there's just
straight up honey
they just gave me a pack of honey like
okay you do need for the biscuit you do
need sauce for the
mickey d's ones so let's review i mean
we got so much sauces insane
ranch sweet heat yeah fried chicken
wednesday honey mustard
buffalo hit you with that buffalo huh
interesting um that [ __ ] with it that
kind of changes the whole character of
the nugget to be honest
it becomes a buffalo wing at that point
there's so much sauce here it's kind of
obscene like
kids in africa could drink the sauce hmm
it's true [ __ ] wednesday night i
shouldn't let it go to waste fried
chicken
but what am i drink at all smoothie slam
it
i love that it's like
no no okay well anyway
okay so i mean do they have the best
nuggies they're very heavy i'll see that
like
if i'm sit if i'm sitting down like okay
i have [ __ ] to do today
mcdonald's nuggies because these nuggies
are going to slow you down there is a
lot of bread
there's a lot of deep fry those nuggets
are hearty and they're going to
come right for your heart as well
that's what i'm saying what uh what is
the price difference compared
to these versus great questions zach
let's get a price compare
that's a great question jack that's
fantastic i do think it's important
because when you're talking about value
if these nuggies are gonna set you back
like you know 50 bucks
then i can't co-sign it i can't
eight nuggets will be priced at four
dollars is that
is that accurate okay so it was really
cheap
that's us that's us that's sussy is
[ __ ] sushi as [ __ ]
well mcnuggets are 20-piece for five
dollars
yeah but are they really yeah the
mcnuggies is just
goo that they bread i i like it
i like that i'm not saying that's not
good but you gotta be honest as good
yeah it looks like majin buu yeah i got
you let me show you how mcdonald's
nuggies are made
and nothing's wrong but like how
chick chick chick chicken nuggets
you're going to show us how these are
made and i really don't want to see this
well here i'm going to avert my eyes
we make a cut how do we get from this to
this
irresistible little asteroids of
battered chicken
asteroids
what makes them asteroids weirdo
crashing into your stomach
and colon cancer wreaking havoc
on your body like an asteroid to earth
in a blender and make a mcnugget
even more disturbing the pink elephant
in the room
what are legitimately in mcnuggets is
there pink goop this
pink goop a photograph that is snaked
around the internet with the caption can
you guess
what mcdonald's food item this is it's
said to be the entire chicken
eyes guts bones ground up into something
called
mechanically separated poultry that's it
nice i see alaskan born
but pink goo won't go away for years
mcdonald's has been trying to kill girl
you gotta do that oh my gosh wow
she is and now i'm bringing a lot of
flavor to this report wait
was there pigs squealing in the no that
was the uh
psycho soundtrack this photo
okay i thought it was screaming animals
and now mcdonald's of canada has taken
the goo by the horns
directly addressing the question in a
super bowl commercial
seen only in canada what's actually in
the nuggets
is there any pink goop nope nada none
mcdonald's once i don't [ __ ] believe
that nuggets yeah we've released a video
tour
starting with whole chickens the breast
meat is set aside to make mcnuggets
dumping it into the grinder and adding
the ground chicken breast meat
to the blender with some seasonings and
some chicken skin
that's pretty much it ground up breast
meat i'd love to believe that
and here's what actually we have so it's
very different yeah
i mean why i the pink is it that
different
well the other one was more pink it's
not
i mean that could just be a white
balance on the camera thing right
science experts told cnn that mcdonald's
seems to be giving the straight
scoop though of course there's nothing
healthy about all the fat and salt in
mcnuggets
how dare there is one other secret
revealed on the tour
the four chicken mcnuggets shapes the
ball the bell the boot and the bow tie
the ball the bell the boot the bow tie
do you see any of those things
this woman is such a [ __ ] she's on a
warp bath dude
the belt the boot and the board type the
bow tie what kind of [ __ ] are they
trying to feed us here
hard-hitting journalism it's a ball is
this a bell there's a boot
i am puzzled by the bow tie maybe that's
a bow tie no that's a boot
does this look like a bow tie to you
wait so the shapes aren't random
mcnuggets oh they no it doesn't seem
like it wow
you got the bow the belt and the bow tie
damn what do you understand
i get it now i get it do you remember
when there was like a chicken mcnugget
that went on ebay that looked like
george washington
wait i wait do you remember that i don't
remember george
i don't remember george washington but i
remember nuggies that looked funny going
up
yeah there was one that was like i swear
i swear to god wait i gotta send you
this picture
this i i guess it was probably because
of what i just my recent search history
but i started to type george washington
no way and look at what the autocomplete
on
george washington chicken nugget well
let's see some let's see this nugget
this famous nugget
it like it sold like it was listed on
ebay for is this it
maybe it is oh i see it i do not
i definitely see it how do you not see
it you can see the wig the nose here
here's the nose sorry here's the nose
here's the chin
oh okay the wig the eye that's george
washington the nugget bro that's a
million dollar nugget
that's that's why she just doesn't have
like which
no yeah like a hook nose yeah the
[ __ ] nugget
dude this dan that's america right there
that's what you're gonna dare you
you're not a patriot sir you don't love
your country
that is america right there how much
does nugget sell for
well let's find out how do you preserve
a nugget like this you know you dropped
some seriously sold for eight thousand
one hundred dollars
[Laughter]
that's a nug now that's america dan and
shame on
you sir i i acknowledge my mistake
that's america
that's america and an apple pie
george washing shape nuggets for a
thousand
that's america that's america
pink to make chicken nuggets and then
they come out looking
george washington that's america
that's america apple pies for one dollar
it's hard to compete with him on the
lyric side to be honest with you zach
can we get the instrumental yeah here we
go i don't i don't think that exists can
we get the separate track please
i think i might have to make one you
could probably recreate it yeah
do whatever you got to do man there's
some of those
some people are very good at uh
extracting you know they
they are able to mix it in a way to take
the vocals out
really yeah so if somebody in the
audience knows uh how to do that
can we get oh my god you guys we have
great news we have not only we haven't
found an abraham lincoln chicken nugget
so this is great
that one's far more accurate that one's
far more this one's probably even more
valuable than
what you think that's more accurate than
the washington because the nose shape
actually makes sense the water why are
you concerned about the nose like
excuse me if you go back to jail let me
let me do a side by side here guys on
the nuggets and we can kind of
did this one sell for any meaningful sum
is it because george washington is our
founding father so
his likeness in a nugget might be worth
more money let's say
um some people call the civil war the
second founding of the nation
and therefore abraham lincoln would in a
way be a founding father as well
interesting so so do we have a sale on
this one that we can pull up
for how much it's sold for yeah i mean
that abraham nugget is looking pretty
well according to some this is a more
accurate nugget
four score and seven nugs ago dude
that george washington one i'm sorry
it's a profile
that's the whole point and the nose
shape is very important in a profile i'm
really
fine with features i'm not hating how
hooked the nose is
he doesn't have a nose like that i'm not
hating on this washington
nugget like you or dad and i mean this
one looks more like conan o'brien than
abraham lincoln
i do see that too yeah no but it's got
the prominent chin which
lincoln definitely has well i didn't
even know we should apparently guys be
checking your nuggies you might be of
winning the lottery if they
are likened to any prominent oh you
could american presidents
right i believe there was one that was
shaped like jesus too
that one's gonna be worth a lot i
believe because you know jesus shows
himself in mysterious ways so he could
just pop up in a nuggy and that's his
message to humanity like hey i didn't
forget you guys
you know i'm not finding any statistics
about
uh famous nuggies um
among us nuggie for a hundred thousand
that didn't really sell oh yeah i
remember yeah yeah
that that was a troll it didn't sell for
that much but was someone was listing it
yeah that's a shame you know
it's an impossibility when we tried to
sell our beanie it went to like a
billion dollars
i wish there was a way to get limited to
verified bids only
like they do on when we're doing the
nfts you have to actually put the money
in escrow yeah collateral right yeah
yeah
that's fair because i'm still waiting on
my billion dollar check for that beanie
now i found an article from 2005
about an honest abe french fry
a french fry that somebody bid fifty
thousand dollars for
well hold on let me see a photo of that
i gotta say
pretty lackluster
dude you guys are out of control that
literally just looks like a cut likes
what the [ __ ] this was the year 2005. it
was a simpler time
you know and we weren't as cynical back
then
i could see people getting excited the
anna's abe french fry this is like nfts
before nfts
the french fry scam yeah and yeah
i mean it lacks the prominent chin that
i was talking about earlier there's
there's a lot of issues here well let's
read fast food king mcdonald's ran a
jokey commercial oh it's a joke oh no so
oh i see so it was part of a super bowl
commercial
now someone is apparently bidding 50 000
for the honest ape fry
all right so this fry has pr it has that
was a prominence
so it didn't naturally prominence how do
you call that when you're trying to
verify art
his like the legitimate of art you call
it prominence
prominence i am not uh as cultured as
you
because i've never heard of that term
before but maybe cam cameron you know
what i'm talking about right
it's the authenticity of you you you
verify
the history of the art to verify it's
real
it's called prominence or something
providence of your artwork how is it how
is it
a province prov no whatever it's got a
problem
he hip-hop there's a new one doesn't he
want to make it he pop anonymous
he's got a it's got a story so this i
guess this is a valuable french fry
right i'm a little disappointed though
it's a rigged fry this humongous one
though boy
[Music]
right anyway shout out to mcdonald's
making cultural waves
right big big round of applause for
mcdonald's
yeah okay so final verdict
popeye's chicken all right honestly i
think it i think honestly i think it's a
matter
of preference i think they're both good
in their own right
and like this one's heavier the
mcdonald's one is lighter
i don't know because right now i feel
kind of icky i feel kind of icky i'll be
honest
taking the cowards way out right now
offensive and coward
coward i might like mcdonald's better
after sitting on it really yeah i might
because there is like an
aftertaste sitting in your stomach well
it's
yeah it's a ton of deep-fried oil right
and that one
soaks a lot of oil you see how big this
nugget is man like that is a lot
it's a lot of grease it's a lot of
grease some
ian what do you think yeah i'm not
feeling too hot
yeah exactly it feels heavy yeah i
remember the
year or two ago when they first made the
spicy chicken sandwich and you all went
crazy about it didn't you
all have like explosive diarrhea
i don't know why you guys i've been
having those a lot these days it's hard
to keep track i
see i don't know why you guys keep doing
this to yourselves sam are you still
popeyes over mcnutt mcdonald's nug
she likes mcnuggets but but she likes
puppies
popeyes she's going to popeye's route
okay well bag of turret you know flaming
turd bat
the more time goes by the more i hate it
really i don't like it
i'm out and you can take all this
[ __ ] sauce with you too
i wish you guys could see my table right
now ethan do you like chick-fil-a
chick-fil-a's okay you know the meat the
chicken
is a little weird there it's a little
weird
how so like in one like it's very hated
gay people
they it's homophobic to eat fresh for
chick-fil-a first of all so shame on you
for even asking
it's very thick and when you get to the
center of the chicken it gets a little
spongy
it gets a little like what is exactly
going on here
interesting so i've never noticed that
but i'll have to look out for it next
i do like it though i don't know
i feel like puking i'll be honest with
you guys i'm gonna not feel good right
now
oh no
i'm afraid that theater might got me
sick though so don't you guys i don't
actually feel sick
like illness i just feel like puking
right now
i'd rather look at joe rogan's nipples
than [ __ ] eat another
pack of nuggies that that bad huh i
would rather
drink from joe rogan's nipple
right okay you guys want to do our um
our hot takes we want to do another hot
takes
which is unpopular opinion
oh [ __ ]
i think i have a good one actually and
let me guess mine is gonna be the only
real
unpopular opinion like last time dan's
gonna be like i think
animals should be treated well no no and
everyone's like
wow dan is such a good guy he thinks
animals should be treated well
that wasn't that was in my opinion that
wasn't it it was
don't eat pigs which wow that is an
unpopular opinion in the united states
of america
dan please stand up stand up dan
i'm not standing up stand up there no
the president has asked you this
don't sit down he's sitting down dan
please stand up
stand up dan okay he's sitting
all right i hope dan is gonna be okay
all right who wants to go first zach i'm
calling you i'm calling on you to go
first what did your
um uh popular opinion please my
unpopular opinion
um which which i i've asked around and
it's
you know definitely sparked some
controversy
i don't think reese's peanut butter cups
are good
have never found them enjoyable and i
i i think it's an awful [ __ ] candy
okay let me ask you a follow-up
the cups you don't like do you like the
reese's pieces
no i i don't like any combination of
peanut butter and chocolate
okay i i think it's a horrible
combination dan seems to be upset by
that
it's a hot take look it's like yeah
that's a [ __ ] scorching hot take
amen his own man that is an sss tier
candy right but dan are you talking
about the cup or the pieces all of it
and just all of it no he's making a
wider point here than chocolate
chocolate and peanut butter don't go
well together in my opinion
me it's your hot take i get it yeah i
get it
and it's a draw you have to defend your
position zach man
all right anytime i've bitten into a
[ __ ] shitty reese's peanut butter cup
it's been dry you're thirsty after
it's right it is dry it's just look i
know you want it to be wet
you just wanna you and you wanna moisten
chocolate you don't want
your [ __ ] noodles so you don't you
don't like
you'll eat ass but not a reese's peanut
butter cup
basically yeah well if ironically i
imagine that that they have
a similar texture i'm just saying
i've never enjoyed it and it's my
opinion you know it's my right to you
know what zack
i like them but i understand i get like
it's
it can be very dry the texture yeah and
it's a and it's a lot to
um it's a lot it is a lot thank you
ethan
thank you that being said shame on you
i'm just kidding i i get it i like those
though you know so that's my hot take
okay interesting a little controversy
around here i don't get the hype either
okay ian's back thank you ian i
appreciate that
i wouldn't say i don't get that hype
okay well ian so what's your hot take
mine's oh god mine's gonna get me
cancelled for sure
um ian's like i don't like this
minority group this is definitely gonna
rob people out and be like wow that's
shocking
uh i think that
nintendo is kind of bad wow wow
that's a good one okay back that up
i think that if you don't like mario or
zelda you're kind of screwed
a little bit with that company um that's
a good observation
like i'm over it i got people trying to
tell me like oh you got to play mario
golf now
i'm like i don't want to play a golf
game why are we convincing ourselves
that we want to play golf games
that's all that's that's all you got to
do but it's like and that's a really
good point and
it's like have you guys really not
thought of a a new
uh franchise in like 20 years it's all
it's all zelda and mario i mean pokemon
and pokemon it works which by the way
the new pokemon for switch was such an
abomination it's such a dog [ __ ] stupid
game
it's so pointless oh my god it's really
popular it's so [ __ ]
or well i haven't played a pokemon game
since
read the original so i i don't have a
strong opinion
on this well let me clarify so i don't
let me clarify in case anyone's mad
there was i don't know if a new pokemon
came out but it was like the 3d pokemon
world one
and the switch so easy it's like you
can't
lose a single fight yeah they've been
making them easier and easier it's like
you
can't lose a fight if you just close
your eyes and push it's like it's so
pointless
yeah i mean nintendo makes games for for
kids but
okay listen zelda zelda is harder than
most of these games that people play on
the daily
i mean i know a lot of people talking
about pokemon pokemon you have pokemons
no i'm talking about this specific
pokemon that came out was bad
one of the the pikachu one
the first one for the switch i think so
detective pikachu
i looked up how many mario games there
have been and it's been like
i think 220 plus mario games
so it's like come on and none of them
come and they were close to mario
teaches typing
1994. so your point your thesis here ian
is
enough mario enough zelda
nintendo is resting on its laurels and
don't tell me to play splatoon because i
know people in the comments
well they made splatoon come on yeah i'm
with you
that's a [ __ ] you know i'm gonna back
you up in that i have had a switch since
it came
out i played zelda i played mario and
there's no [ __ ] other games to play
there's nothing animal crossing i think
you're yeah i like animals
in 2002 as well that was great the games
are so good that
two games to carry a whole system
they're good games but like i haven't
touched it
the only time i play switch is if i'm
playing something that's like available
that's like an indie game available on
all platforms
right i mean the switch itself is a
great console
i i don't see i don't know if i can
fully fully back you up on this but
i am thinking about it and you're right
all the games that i've enjoyed on the
switch haven't been like nintendo games
even
breath of the wild was uh released on
the previous
system that isn't even a switch game
yeah well because the wii u was a flop
and i will say that
right i i feel like i play a lot of
indie game
things too i feel like um you probably
haven't heard of them
no no like you know i've had
ethan and i have played some of them too
you know like hollow knight in haiti
yeah exactly yeah those were great
celeste and all these games
i feel like these should be nintendo
games but nintendo's not making games
like this
they're just not they're just making
mario golf four again
so mario party 27. the current uh the
current smash brothers is good
super smash brothers is the end off yeah
but the sixth one right
like the seventh or eighth or twenty
second i played it in 1998.
so ian let me ask you would you say that
nintendo's the most legendary
gaming system company i mean i think
yeah they've built up so much goodwill
that they can just you know
do this nostalgia forever love it so i
don't know
well just making them legendary doesn't
doesn't really
because i mean you know you could say uh
o.j simpson's a legendary football
player but that doesn't really mean
anything
uh it doesn't really give us a full
context greatest running back of all
time
and don't get me wrong i think they make
great games like with mario
you know like mario odyssey and you know
what
it's funny because i'm i've been the one
that's been kind of yeah
on this take-in but mario odyssey i
thought was such a disappointment that
game sucked
i didn't finish that was the new one
yeah it was short it was flat it wasn't
and like you were saying uh you were
complaining about the pokemon game my
biggest issue with it was it was for
babies
like i don't know why they make it it
was there was no challenge
stop with the baby game that's that's my
other complaint with them is
like there's so many adult nintendo
players but they they just expect the
adults to play baby games instead of
like
trying to dive diverge a little bit and
make games for babies but also make some
games that grow up
with their audience they just ignore
that completely they're making a new uh
metroid right
it's gonna stop more if i use super easy
it's super cartoony it's gonna suck
mark my words remember i said this well
i hope you're wrong because
those games are cool i do hate that
they're making the games easier that is
annoying
like when they remade the ocarina of
time they made like the water temple
easier and a few other parts easier that
was annoying are they really mm-hmm
dude it's like wow bro i was stuck on
the water temple for like a month when i
was a kid oh yeah no who the hell are
these little chickens today to not
talk about those water levels yep
kids these days they don't know they
have it they don't know how
easy they have it i mean like going back
to what you said um
your question i mean you might say that
that um
ryan cavanaugh is a legendary uh uh
don't producer film producer but that
doesn't it's not really an
endorsement because you end up going
bankrupt right he ran relativity media
into the ground
after being one of the most successful
studios in the industry exactly for a
long time yeah and somehow he still
managed to run it into the ground which
is
impressive in its own way yeah which is
what i think is going to happen to
chiller
all right um thank you ian
a bee i had one that dan wanted me to
really say but we've talked so much
about food that i think i want to do a
different one
i don't even remember what you're
talking it's about raw potatoes
oh yeah what the [ __ ] no say that one i
like raw potatoes but that's not my hot
take that's weird
that is a weird [ __ ] yeah he said that
to me the other day i was like it's raw
potatoes what are you like an eye
you're like like an an irish in a potato
famine where you're just like eating
rubbish oh
we found a lot of ways to make potatoes
when i was a kid but yeah like the raw
potatoes were just a snack
with some salt is that healthy is that
okay to eat raw potatoes i don't know
sure it's fine i don't know i've heard
different things but
why somebody's can you eat a raw potato
safely i have doubts about that
i mean you can eat other vegetables raw
like broccoli and [ __ ]
yeah some [ __ ] you have to cook
my hot taste raw potatoes are more
likely to cause digestive issues and may
contain
more ant anti-nutrients oh that's
interesting anti-matter
yeah i've never even heard of ant
it smashes into into nutrients and
nullifies them
so mine says it made me stronger but
in the spirit of balance it does say yet
they are higher in vitamin c
and resistant starch which i mean based
on the context
that's a good thing starch ain't [ __ ]
with me okay raw potatoes i've never
heard of that before but okay go ahead
yeah my hot take is that i like the
twilight movies
i had a feeling i do i don't know i i
mean like they're cheesy the acting's
horrible but like i i thoroughly enjoy
them i was dating a girl at the time and
i really didn't want to watch the first
one and then i did and i was all in
i haven't seen any of them so i
am hard pressed to challenge you on that
because i've never seen them
so i don't really know if they're good
or not i just know they're really
popular with the ladies
and um twilight rotten tomato i really
don't know much about it either but
um the reason that i said i knew it is
because you had it on
here at the studio recently and i think
you were kind of trying to play it off
like it was just on ironically but
you knew a lot about it somewhat yeah i
did slip someone put
someone did put it on i think maybe sam
put it on but then
you asked the question and i answered
and uh someone said oh how'd you that's
all right that's right
or samson like that's a direct quote
from the right
yeah i know he knows this he knows his
stuff so so what do you think about 50
shades of grey
no i can't do that no so i never watched
it
oh i'm getting into that you even
cosplayed as one of the members of
of twilight is that
even cosplay who am i oh i got it funny
ian
which one of these which one am i i
better be [ __ ] edward
i mean i think the guy from centers yeah
i don't the look yeah he's got that same
kind of hair carlisle
were these the vampires or werewolves
this is a still from the movie
yeah yeah um i hate to break this to you
but
twilight saga new moon which one was
that
that was the second one yeah that one
has a 20
on rotten tomato i agree that's one
where she went more towards uh
team jacob i'm team edward let me read
some reviews
interesting let's see
here you know all you need to talk about
someone said even twilight
fans i suspect will find themselves
bored of this
two hours and 10 minutes of rambling
pointless drivel where nothing of any
real interest happens
i am yeah and that's what happens when
you're not loyal i mean i don't know
ab explained to me because when it was
on one of the characters
who i guess is a vampire yes right um
was
um out during the daylight and i'm like
how is it he's he's a vampire right
yeah well how is he out during the day
oh they just get a little uncomfortable
and
and they sparkle when they're in the
sunlight i'm like
vampire what a [ __ ] nightmare bro
yeah and then but they they made that
exemption just to create these sexy
moments where
with her it's like if you're in the sun
you [ __ ]
die that's really that part what do
people know about vampires they suck
blood they turn into bats and they can't
go in the sunlight like it's one of the
foundational parts of being a vampire
you can't you can't flip the script like
that yeah
what are you doing dan asked me so
what's the downside then of being a
vampire in this world and i'm like well
the cullens the main family they only
eat animals so surviving off animal
blood is like surviving off a tofu for
them and which doesn't really sound like
to me
like a bad drawback at all here's one
review from
bob grimm from tuscan weekly he said oh
god make it stop
okay yep they're not like
i'm not saying they're any like
godfather anything like that they're
good movies i mean they're bad movies
but like
they're so bad they're good and you i
don't know you want to see what happens
but the cgi for their daughter and the
last one is by far the worst cgi i've
ever seen in any film hold that up i've
heard the sea
pulled me up but i heard that there's
some really bad cgi moments that i want
to watch
you know abe i i'm going to give him a
shot i'm going to watch him
okay i'm excited for you to come report
yeah i'm going to give him a shot
does your girl like him have she's uh i
don't think she's seen him but i showed
him too michael
here here a b this one's good oh my god
what the [ __ ]
baby this this this hits home a perfect
movie for pre-teen
and early teen girls but a letdown for
the rest of the audience due to its slow
whiny pace and tone jesus
fighting hey you you got to see this
picture that amy the [ __ ] is this
baby what the [ __ ] is this so
the daughter so the daughter is half
human
and i'm the spoiler alert sorry half
human half vampire so she ages rapidly
her name is renesmee
and so your name to have the same look
at the rest of me renesme
i believe it's after both mothers renee
and
okay whatever the [ __ ] is i'm not making
fun of you guys
am i boom you like that no it's cg right
okay
that's black magic dude i don't know
what the [ __ ] that is
that's scary i don't like it i don't you
want more do another one oh yeah
there's more
[Music]
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
wait it's just she has like old she has
like grown up lady hair
right he's saying that she like ages
rapidly
oh did they try to cgi a real person's
face on her or something horrible it was
so that she looks like yeah the
older version does she talk like an
adult
uh no
she yeah she's only kid for like a week
maybe
is there any scenes i'd like to see by
the blood of the lamb by the blood of
the lamb god
no that is not from the movie dude no
this isn't from the movie i just found
this one oh okay all right
this i don't believe is related it's a
picture of arnold schwarzenegger
kind of similar though in the style of
cti
[Music]
hmm okay well that's quite a confession
quite a confession watch i haven't
watched them all in a long time
just to let you know so i don't know
what's the first one did you watch it
with the girl
you must have yeah that's what he
started okay so in high school
my girlfriend at the time wanted to
watch him and we watched the first three
and i was so curious about the fourth
one that i secretly and i never told his
soul not even her
that i bought the book and i read it to
see what the [ __ ] happens oh
you then i just wanted to move and
actually super spoil it for yourself
here
a b the soundtrack will be smothered by
the sounds of screaming girls
and laughing at them may be the only
pleasure you get out of this
arduously added angst fest
team edward baby for easily impressed
audience that equate
big lowest common denominator box office
receipts with quality
here is a perfect movie for them they
constantly check their cell phones at
while they sit in the dark
didn't like some big fast food chain do
like a team edward
team jacob thing i think it was like
burger king or something probably
probably they were everywhere okay well
thank you for coming forward with that
that's a bit good it's a great break so
i commend you
you should stand uh wesley snipes and
blade instead
much better vampire movie it's a great
movie i [ __ ]
yeah but blade it's sad to say blade
can't even take this on i think edward
would [ __ ] blade up
oh you shut the [ __ ] up he's got a
samurai sword he'll get his
[ __ ] is edward some kind of special
vampire is he is he like a dope vampire
is he just a hunky yeah and also he has
you clearly don't know the blade lore
because blade is a day walker because
he's only half vampire and he can
walk inside oh no i don't i only know
from and he has a samurai sword he
doesn't even sparkle in this he's wesley
he wins either way [ __ ] is
always trying to stay uphill wait is
edward's a special vampire is he just a
normal vampire well
he has some abilities uh he he could
read other people's minds and also he's
very sexy
oh ooh can read minds he can remind some
vampires have different abilities his
sister could predict the future
they're making [ __ ] up those are not
vampire abilities who would win in a
fight dracula or edward
the steins well the cullens as a you
as a unit you can't [ __ ] with them by
the end that's all i'll say [ __ ]
dracula
dracky level this will eat his head he
can't do [ __ ] because
they'll see him coming alice will
predict the future you guys know what
i'm talking about
this is that's on vampire that's like
wizard [ __ ] i mean
hey i didn't write the word dan do you
have one for us
thank you baby i do i do um
and it's sort of a meta hot take because
we are
talking about unpopular opinions here
and as
um everyone in this room is aware i have
acquired a nickname of sorts
uh dan the hater on the show go ahead
zach
there it is and i would like to assert
to you all today
that there is someone here who is a
far bigger hater than me you want to
take a guess who would it be
interesting oh man i don't know
you're you just you just said it in a
way
ethan is the [ __ ] hater of course i'm
the biggest hater i have a whole
i have my built my whole career about
being a hater that was
yes so why am i dan the hater he's ethan
the hater
we all have careers ethan
please stand up i like far more things
than ethan ethan hates everything
he hates [ __ ] popeye's chicken
[Laughter]
i'm not the only one that didn't like
the popeyes you know what you
you know what you're right you don't
even like chicken period
ethan klein well that's actually not
true you're writing off the whole
thing making it all worse no i actually
like chickens so much that i don't eat
them
interesting wow that that's a [ __ ]
360
that is interesting well uno reverse
card on you there
yeah that's a good call yeah no um what
made me think of it is actually your
take the other day where you you just
straight up said that you don't like
cats and like
one there's somebody here who who
doesn't like cats and i'm the hater
like please i'm not the only person in
the world that doesn't like cats okay
i was the only one by the way i was
thinking of bringing out today that i
don't like cats is my unpopular tag
but i felt like it was too obvious look
cats compared to dogs
with peace and love it's like they don't
offer the same companionship
they're so needy and then they're hot
and cold it's like i don't need this hot
and cold
again wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait-wait hold on
wait ian i'm giving him the rope he's
hanging himself okay just
let him talk you're telling me cats are
needy
have you met shredder yeah honestly no i
maybe needy's not the right word i think
it's more like um
they're very like they're like these
they think they're better than everyone
in fact yeah that makes dogs need so
much more so much
[ __ ] from cats are like self-sufficient
like they're not they're
so much i've got clawed i've gotten hurt
by cats
disrespected by cats so many more times
than dogs
dude just yesterday wallace would have
ripped my throat out
yeah well wallace is a kind of a wild
one for sure
your dogs have [ __ ] in this office like
20 times
you want to talk about disrespect to be
fair i'm a dog lover myself i did step
in alfredo's [ __ ] and try
okay that didn't don't ever say i don't
love you because i'm gonna get [ __ ] for
that i hate cats
you're allergic you're allergic i'm
allergic and they they try to kill me
first
that's the thing there oh i feel like
cats are always attacking me they're
taking swipes at me
and their clothes are so [ __ ] sharp
like you know what okay
so i don't i don't like cats and they
don't like me i'm happy with that dan
i don't need it and i'm like ocd clean
and they get just hair everywhere i much
rather
[ __ ] ocd clean i rather clean [ __ ] all
day from a dog than
hair all over all my clothes i agree
with that
this may surprise you guys i will take
hair over feces thank you this may
surprise you that's the coffee
she'll take but my dogs for the most
part [ __ ] and piss
outside for the most i've
yet to see evidence of that i've seen
him piss on zach's
bag at least three times yeah he's the
other day
i'm a dog lover i love those yeah he
shouldn't have done that i'm sorry
okay it's not fair to turn this into a
catchphrase i love it i tried
you did ethan did it i don't like that
we're going down this path i love dogs
i i have this i didn't even bring it up
you brought it up i didn't want to go
i love cats don't cancel me but cats are
[ __ ] they're [ __ ] i'm telling you
i used to live with a girl in college
who had a cat and the cat will come into
my room and piss all over my [ __ ]
so like don't try to start this
conversation like oh dog's cat
i had cats that was pissed all my [ __ ]
and i would be like what the [ __ ] are
you doing i would
pick up the cat it would claw me i would
throw it i was in perpetual war with
this guy
as a kid growing up i had a cat that
lived in our [ __ ] garage that the
previous owners left there
and i would try to be nice to the cat i
would go and say hi kitty and it would
[ __ ] scratch
the [ __ ] out of me so i'm sorry cats are
[ __ ]
i have traumatic experiences with cats
i'm here live that's not
i'm not a cat okay
thank you for doing my segment for me
proving my point
i don't want to hear the dan the hater
thing anymore go ahead
when this is going on when this when
this is before us
the song's about you what can i do it's
got your name in it
your hot take is that i'm a bigger
[ __ ] than you
well hold on i didn't say [ __ ] i said
that
listen i've acquired like i was
explained i have acquired a reputation
over time on this show
as a hater which i think is
partially true but if we're going to be
assigning a hater title
i mean it's there's no comparison like
you said you built a
you built an entire career i'm being a
hater
just because i'm a hater doesn't mean
you can't be one dan meanwhile like i'm
i'm the one over here laughing at all
your jokes
you know like i'm not oh i'm not hating
me i'm just saying it's like i'm not
like
i mean there are some people here i
think you're a very nice man
and and what would you do should we stop
calling you dan the hater
is that buggy like legitimately down
yeah does that bother you it actually
doesn't i don't really care
but we got to make dan the guy who
laughs dan the lover
dan the lover that's right i'll make
that i'll make that i'll make it yeah oh
we'll switch we'll flip it for you
depending on my mood because i mean i'm
not going to say that i
can't be a hater it definitely can be
but i just i
i don't think it's fair that it defines
me that's fair
especially when there's other bigger
haters in such close proximity i'll take
that
i'm a huge hater i wish i wasn't i wish
i like things
i don't like things i hate things and
for the most part
i've used that to my advantage in life
but i am a
i'm a massive hater i wish that i wasn't
but here
here i am with a picture of [ __ ] ryan
cavanaugh and brett
and harvey weinstein behind me uh one is
suing ela
one's in jail for our word you know take
pick your poison you know what i'm
saying
yeah i hate both of them so here i am
love you guys
hate these guys
ryan kavanaugh ladies and gentlemen
maybe do you have one or not a b love do
you have one
yeah but mine isn't as controversial or
well
okay maybe maybe actually i'm i'm about
[ __ ] on america
okay you're about did you say you're
about to [ __ ] on america
right so i'm gonna drop a bomb here
sweden has better candy than america
better candy or better snacks but
everything's fresh that's sweet yeah you
got that
candy yeah you know what sweden does
have really good candies like the sweet
is swedish fish
actually swedish or is that just the
name of it maybe i don't know actually i
don't know about that
sweetest fish
well i was about to maybe segue this to
send you guys a like killed a care
package yeah
that's a great idea yes
so i can literally prove you guys or
prove me wrong or right
oh here's it i love that idea this is an
interesting little piece of trivia here
about swedish fish are you ready
oh thank you it's made by a swedish
company for
the united states well it originated in
sweden
and they started exporting it to the us
but i
love oh it was a hit in the u.s swedish
fields are awesome you know i used to
work with swedish people a lot when i
was living in israel
and they used to bring back the candy
and it's fantastic they have phenomenal
candies i don't know
you know they've got i i'm with you
not only the candy we got the ships
we've got the fifa we got the
i mean literally everything the
chocolate vintage
you say chips you mean french fries or
potato chips
potato ships you're claiming that sweden
has better potato chips than the united
states of america yeah what do you have
lace love doritos don't freak yourself
no
you gotta you gotta check you yeah yeah
hold on u.s
[ __ ] is king of the chip game bro
step off oh no
oh no well we need to do a little a
little exchange
yeah a cultural exchange you send us
we'll send you some bomb ass [ __ ]
american chips and no we're not talking
about lays
yeah i mean lays is international we got
there's the stuff that's really popping
these days is like these kettle corn
chips you know
we'll just cut old chips cattle yeah no
corn love so you're telling me
let's do this you're saying candy
potato chips well spika i can't we don't
even have speakers so you wanted that
one
i mean i have spika every day they don't
call it here they just call it big fat
wait what what is spika what is speaking
it's like afternoon snack time
oh yeah no it's like it could be
anything anything sweet pretty much
i see yeah i do speak every day it's
just called being fat here
yeah right no but the swedes are like
generally healthy they just have like
tea and coffee and have snacks there but
they love the spica when i was in sweden
everyone's like you could just freak out
with us come through
with everyone's like it's all crazy
about doing this
yeah that's how they no yeah it's a
thing like a
time or i don't know is it that uh i
googled it
yeah they said come do a spika with us
it's just because a concept
a state of mind and attitude an
important part of the swedish culture
yeah
i like that americans don't have [ __ ]
like that like cool cultural things
or like a siesta you can just put a word
before the fikia for example like
anything like that well it's like a
cinnamon and bun
and some coffee maybe maybe some uh
something good to drink
a coke yeah yeah
you're saying it wrong it's f i k a what
did you do
i'm sorry did you just name coke as like
one
thing that's kind of trashy to be honest
hang on i think the issue here is that
that is an american snack and just
because you call it fika
doesn't mean that you can take credit
for it okay bro
sweden is made of a swedish walker
though that's way better
by the way it probably is better
well the way i understand fika is like
coffee or tea if i saw someone doing
coke at
fika i would be i would just flip the
table well that's for the kids
maybe the adults would drink coffee or
something like that mm-hmm okay
i like maybe we should start doing fika
in the office i
i think we i mean it sounds like we kind
of do already what would we call puppets
it's like you dedicate the time so you
have like um
pastries coffee or tea and then you say
it's fika time
you sit and then we all enjoy the fika
am i right love
yeah in sweden we even have laws to
allow fijian
whoa it's not literally a figure loss
but
or ethical law but we have for every
hour you
you get five minutes to do something and
that's perfect for africa
i love [ __ ] swedes man they know how
to live out there
auto suggestion just came up can you
fika alone you can do it alone you can
do it with friends you can do it at home
in a park or at work wait love do you
fika alone
sure i mean you pick it yourself
comes between let's say you eat lunch
and
like towards the evening you get a bit
hungry or maybe
like you want to eat something small you
you take a fake yeah
okay let me ask you this can you fika at
while you're like on your computer or
does the fika require you to sit
separately and enjoy your time with the
food and drink
no no i mean fika is a very wide
word so wait it's just a snack i thought
it was like this holy thing where you
sit together
i'm faking with some footage i think i
should should probably
it's it's am i doing a figure with
popeyes
yeah i guess see i mean but now
now the figure's just [ __ ] no no no
but the figure is
something you plan it's like lunch
but not lunch
[Laughter]
these swedes man they're the best i
[ __ ] love sweden
but every time i say sweden where what
part of sweden do you live in yeah
what's your address
yeah right what what city are you in or
what part of
oh you don't want to say well i can say
yeah what part is somebody's going to
get doxxed
no i just don't know i'm from shopping
have you been
i was just in stockholm is it near there
uh it's a bit underneath actually it's
underneath the
second biggest lake okay sounds pretty
underneath living underwater
yeah exactly i mean geography oh yeah
is it a big city or is it like a small
it's probably like the
seventh or eighth okay so it's it's it's
it's small it's not like i can actually
shake it
it's like probably 90 000. oh god that's
small
that's fairly small that's tiny were we
because like mike the small town i grew
up ventura has like a quarter million
yeah i mean i think we have 10 million
in sweden
oh wow 93 000. that's a small town
there's 10 million people in sweden
that's the total population of the
country
i do think it's quite population of
california is like three times as big as
that
well we can verify that quite easily i
mean here population of sweden 10
million yeah that's
crazy that's so little people damn
that's
that's not a lot of speakers going on in
the world california is actually 40
million
just looked it up the reason that sweden
has such little population
is that the birth rate has sharply
declined
um starting in 1975.
well ladies you heard it here first love
is single
love is are you single love yeah
all right we're gonna do something about
that swedish ladies we have an edible
man looking for a fika partner
what's your favorite fika for all the
ladies who are wondering
this is like a legit dating application
for swedes yeah this is break it or make
it
so what's love what's your idea of a
perfect sphinca date
love 69 oh wow
um like some um i don't drink coffee i
don't drink that my coffee
coffee so uh probably have to be
something sweet to drink maybe a coke
oh i don't know nope nope just try again
okay so no i'm forgetting
it's like a cinemabond but better
sounds like a great date girls if you
want to apply to take a speaker with
love
email podcast at hvs3 productions you
know i'm going to film it
what have i done what have i done thank
you dad
yeah sorry love you no stroke and [ __ ]
down here
i am that is so wildly inappropriate
what i am not wearing pants
and put your pants up that's just that's
disgusting get your [ __ ] together back
there didn't we just take sexual
harassment training
[Music]
[Applause]
awful all right well i'm excited for
uh lu for love's fika day look forward
to that
me too
okay i guess it's my turn oh you still
haven't gone
i guess my whole life is just ethan
being the hater
okay here's my hot take i don't know how
much you guys are gonna care about this
this is something that i've held true my
whole life and i will
and i'm finally happy to come out of the
closet and say this
okay with very
very very few exceptions
maybe with like one or two exceptions or
three
[Music]
video game plots are a
horrifying disaster that should be
skipped
at every time video game plots are
horrible
always they're horrible the dialogue the
writing
the story they always [ __ ] suck i
mean often times but
no always no not always
there there are some amazing video game
story lines yeah no there's not
knights are all republic mass effect
yeah
so mass effect is one of the one
exceptions i can think of where i
you play many rpgs because every one of
them and that's
not possible that you've played every
rpg okay dan
the hater exactly i mean that's it i've
played a lot my point is i've played
many many rpgs okay and for the most
part you do not
care for the story lines they are all
[ __ ] i mean if i want if i want to read
a story there's people that are writing
books that are way better
i i just like people put too much
emphasis on video game plots and they
always
[ __ ] suck the voice acting is bad
the writing is weird the plot is not
developed well
it's a video game let me just play the
game i don't need the whole plot like
i'm playing final fantasy 15.
i know people are gonna get mad cause
they say oh i love the story i'm not
you're playing i am you're playing 14
not 14 whatever it is
i am not reading this [ __ ] well then how
can i i'm not good if you're not reading
it
because i tried but it's like i'm not i
don't care i don't care
nobody's going to back me up on this the
last of us
never played listen lots of games have
bad plots for sure so like i mean i'm
not going to
outright nearly everyone i just think
that
i agree with you it's stupid thank you
love thank you
if you want a story there's so many
great books video games are not
i mean they can be a good vehicle for
storytelling but the like 95 95
of them do it in such a horrible way
that it's not even worth entertaining
i think you're just playing the wrong
games yeah yeah mass effect is one of
the only games where i was invested in
the storyline
everything like all the rest of the
bioware games specifically
are so [ __ ] dumb blasphemy
dialogue is like a dude it's like brain
numb it's like i don't
care it's like this girl's looking for a
husband
oh it's like what what game are you
playing
knight of the old republic has a better
star wars story than any star wars film
i mean i i thought i was going to agree
with you but
[Laughter]
i played that game i don't know the
original trilogy is
on par with those games yeah that's
that's absolutely it's on par
but i mean i'm sorry i think the story
of revan is more interesting
i think i think it's better than the
prequels or the sequel trilogy yeah but
those are bad movies you compared to a
good movie
like the original trilogy that's that's
absurd it's got a good story no you're
wrong ethan
it's it's good burn it's not yeah i love
playing games that uh
have a good story but the game itself is
terrible to play
those are like my favorite what what
give me like
like a game where like um like
you're like an army vet and you come
home and your your like
wife has dementia or something and you
gotta like
like find her memory in your old
childhood home
oh like yeah i know i know yeah i know
these weird indie games
that's my jam right there it's that
sounds like a specific game what are you
talking about
that was fantastic where the stories
interwoven with the gameplay bastion
loved that game yeah uh from the same
makers as uh hades which you enjoyed
that right and that had a good yeah i
like haiti it's not really
it's not really okay yeah that
definitely had a story games there are
not many game developers that can weave
the story
into the game that isn't obnoxious trite
or just outright horrible like
dark souls these are games that weave in
a story to the gameplay
where you have to sit and read so much
dumb contrived
garbage [ __ ] uh uh
dialogue and backstory and [ __ ] it's
like no
no no next no
go ahead uh ian no i had nothing to say
i was just
i disagree i just think i think you're
making
too general of a statement here i think
that there's just
there's too many games there's too much
variety types of games genres
there's like five games that have done
it well with the story
i love you backed me up uh uh keep
backing me up please
yeah well we kind of spoke about this
when we were playing or we
we spoke about final fantasy right yeah
yeah yeah and
wait wait wait wait wait did you guys
play final fantasy i don't know
no we just spoke about this okay calm
down calm down
so we are logged in at the same time
i've
leveled 30 levels without reading one
word
in the whole game yeah literally well i
tried at first love
to be fair i mean i gave it a shot no i
didn't well then how do you judge it
also mmos are not like the pinnacle of
storytelling let's be honest like
by the way it's just one example it's
the type of game that i mean there's
millions of players
playing the same storyline nobody chrono
trigger
great story i i will follow that whole
story that was great
what else have you been waiting for yeah
oh that's a deep cut
that's a great it's a popular game i
mean it's kind of i mean it's kind of a
cult
game but yeah okay yeah i played that
one yeah it was great i played it
somewhere well not recent i played it on
that emulator like 10 years ago
right yeah that's how i played it too
ethan let me ask you i'm personally i'm
not a gamer myself i really don't play
but they're
i've played one or two video games what
do you think about gta
well gta is those have fun stories yeah
gta is good because
you know gt is good because i like how
they weave
in the storytelling into the gameplay
more
we come up with so many counter examples
like
i don't know i just i don't know this
take is getting lukewarm real quick
that's something i feel passionate about
i'm saying there are some games that do
it
well
the vast majority are dog [ __ ]
vast majority of books are dog [ __ ] yeah
and i don't read them
okay but the games that people like i
have [ __ ] stories
bioware is the worst bioware makes the
worst and i know what what game are you
talking about bioware is known for
whatever
storytelling yeah and it's so [ __ ]
dumb i wish i could
i know i know mass effect was made by
bioware dan
but what game are you talking about let
me pull it up let me pull up their games
i wish i could show you guys this
dialogue to show how unforgettable their
stories are
um was it dragon age the one i was
playing
i have no idea what you're talking about
it must have been dragon age
that age has a great story too no yeah
no
no it does no yeah
no you're wrong no i'm not really
annoying it's so dumb
you're wrong you're wrong about that
touch some grass dan bioware was the
first company i thought of
counter to your argument because they're
no their stories are exactly and even
they're suck
look this is a hot take it is hot
radioactive
[Laughter]
wait let me let me pull up i gotta find
something of dumb
dumb bioware dialogue while you're
looking that up i'd like to issue a
formal apology for my nintendo statement
earlier
really you're back it's not going to
make people upset i i'm sorry
i'm sorry why are you backing but you
already apologize you might even post it
i don't want the nintendo smoke yet
oh you feel it coming oh yeah donkey's
about to make a video about ian
that's true he would do that yeah
so i love cats okay so wait let's all
let's all make apologies now
and you are you want to understand to
you yeah nathan
well hold on let's start ian go ahead
and make a good apology to the nintendo
fans
i liked a lot of nintendo games when i
was like seven and eight
they had some cool stuff donkey kong is
cool
guys right donkey kong we forgot about
donkey kong zelda
is cool mario's cool animal crossing
your houses and your villages
are so sick and epic are you being
ironic
no no i apologize i'm terribly sorry
breath of the wild is probably my
favorite game
great story on breath of the wild by the
way my god this guy
[Music]
um anyone else want to make an apology
i love cats i love cats i love cats i'm
just allergic that's it
i love cats i've had a bad experience
with a few in my life but i love cats
i've always wanted a cat i love you're
alive that's
i'm not a cat also i apologize
uh for telling dan he needs to touch
grass
i accept i guess still not quite sure
what that means
me neither um i apologize
to everyone who loves video games
apparently i
like uh some video game plots more than
i thought
i want to apologize uh to ethan he's not
a hater he's a
passionate uh man that is full
of positivity and um and also
uh i am
a hater and a technical [ __ ] and
i apologize for saying otherwise well
don't say that about yourself you're a
great guy
we're we're retracting well me too i
think dan's a fantastic guy he's a great
guy i love him
and if anyone's a hater in this building
it's me i have a problem
i hate things and i wish i didn't dan is
not a hater he's a lover
and i apologize to dan
you just undercut my my retraction big
time
his passive aggressive huh you are
hater you are a hater whoa whoa whoa
any other retractions before we move on
zach
i guess we'll just jump on the bandwagon
okay yeah go ahead
um i want to apologize to the whole
america
for talking [ __ ] on your snacks your
ships
yeah that's good to return no actually
no
[ __ ] that okay he's standing wow he's
standing by it
i mean yeah figure for life jesus i love
cats i love all video games and i love
dance
i don't hate me zach has been very quiet
in this retraction segment
i'm not [ __ ] apologizing i hate that
[ __ ] candy
[ __ ] that [ __ ] the reese's people the
reese's pieces people give
you've ruined a childhood for me through
dry ass candy they've ruined your whole
[ __ ] yeah
halloween is my [ __ ] favorite holiday
and you know you get in your bag and
these people hand out these rhesus cops
mini reese's cups
you hate her [ __ ] you okay go ahead zach
we're supposed to be making apologies
but you're doubling down okay
sorry i said that dan um
halloween's my favorite holiday ever
ever since i was a kid
beg my parents even if it's freaking uh
july
can we go to the halloween store
year-round halloween store
yeah i love halloween they're like no
you would think that's not open
i would go trick-or-treating around my
[ __ ] neighborhoods and these
[ __ ] people would hand out these
reese's peanut butter [ __ ] cups
and they would just suck they sucked
because
you could trade that for anything i had
no one to trade it with i didn't have a
lot of friends when i was oh my god now
we found the real problem
anyways these [ __ ] candies [ __ ] up
my childhood
oh my god so [ __ ] you you know you want
to know which candies were always at the
bottom of my halloween bag
nerds and smarties and all that [ __ ] i
was about to say smarties but
uh we've had this discussion before and
the pit but then
i i i take issue with your
your nerds take nerds are good nerds
it's too much spiral okay
but like in terms of halloween they're
not here they're not it is it's left
here
and then what were the ones with the
twizzles were that the smarties yeah
worst f tier fff tier yeah smarties
somebody's really what was on the bottom
of all your guys's halloween bags i'm
curious
candy corn i only i think i actually
said i like candy
anyone want to chime in bottom of the
halloween bag there was like some like
[Music]
pamphlets to change my religion
the neighborhood were you triggered well
i swear to god you've seen them every
year yeah
um that's an f-tier candy listen as fun
as this as fun as this conversation is
uh
we are just about out of time here we
gotta wrap it up oh we're at two hours
well with the break added in holy [ __ ]
we're having too much fun over here off
the rails yeah we are truly off the
rails
we have so much we didn't get to but um
that's okay we'll be back on friday with
the hila
hilda
[Laughter]
the famous hill doggo so guys it's been
a lot of fun
please don't hate any of us for our hot
takes we we apologize and retract
everything so we'll see you on friday
[Music]